Puznik, be prepared for many long nights of frustration and excitement.
Can't wait.
Every NES game released in North America.
I'm Mike. I'm Sean.
And I'm Joe.
And that almost has to be like a poor translation or something, right?
There's just no way you want to describe your game as frustrating ever, right?
Well, I just like, you know, just the fact that it's also like a night of frustration.
Yeah. Just a little, just a little sexual is all.
Many long nights.
Yeah. Oh, wow.
It's been a while.
Yeah. And I guess like the frustration is that you can't solve the puzzle correctly, but like
it could also just be described as like, I'm so frustrated in my purchase, right?
Yeah. There's no, it's open for interpretation.
I mean, also just, you know, taking all the, any sexual undertones out of it.
It's video games are often very frustrating and it's never like, oh yes, I can't wait for
another frustrating game.
Like I feel like I get it.
It's a puzzle. You're going to be like, oh, I want to figure it out, but you don't want to associate it
as a negative. You just want to say challenging.
You just want to say challenging and then you're, you're done with it.
Right. Joe, you actually can't take out any of the sexual subtext though, when talking about
Puzznik because the original arcade version of this game, which came out just a year prior,
did have a sexual component to it.
Whereas you solve puzzles in the arcade cabinet, it would slowly reveal naked women on your
screen. I have seen screenshots of this now that you mentioned it.
And I actually wasn't sure.
Now that you mentioned it.
Now that you mentioned it, I'm not always, I'm not always looking at these screenshots just
every day, but I wasn't sure when I saw it, if it like, is this an official thing or is
this like a bootleg or, you know?
So this was, this was.
No, that's the OG.
That's before this one, this version of it.
Yeah. That is the OG, like Sean said.
And then this is like the get your act together.
We're about to be on a family console.
Can we, can we clean this up a little bit?
And their option was like, well, what if we just don't show them anything at all anymore?
And that's weird. Right?
Like, what do you mean? You're going to show us any kind of reveal puzzle?
Well, that's why you're so frustrated.
It is weird.
I guess it's, I mean, you have to be kind of confident to make that kind of decision.
And just like, oh, I guess the puzzle kind of stands on its own.
Right? Right, right, right.
Where you are already designed the game to be like, well, the puzzle doesn't stand alone.
So we might as well show some naked women.
And you see, you won't see these naked women in the NES game.
You will in the arcade. But the way to see them or move on to the next stage is you basically just slide pieces so that, pieces, squares of different shapes so that all identical shapes touch and disappear together when you have two or more.
And you want to clear off every symbol on the screen so that there are no squares left.
And that's how you move on to the next stage.
So it is very much one of those match games with the puzzle component.
But we really are in full puzzle swing here.
Right? Like, we keep running into puzzle games.
And I think it's interesting that we call these puzzle games and not some more like a lot of adventure games are technically like puzzle games.
If you think about it, they have real puzzles.
This is just one big puzzle.
But this isn't like the same board as like Tetris or even Palamedes or Dr.
Mario. It's a different kind of puzzle game.
Yeah. I mean, it does, again, I don't remember what we said this for last time, the Dice game, Palamedes.
But it does, again, give me right away, like reminds me of Tetris.
But this is even more different than Tetris once you play it.
It almost, I've never played this, but I'm assuming this is a lot closer to something like Candy Crush.
No? Oh, that's interesting.
I don't think, I only know enough about Candy Crush from just seeing my mom play up to like level 100, level 694.
Yeah, I was going to say level 100,000 probably.
Yeah, or something along those lines.
I feel like this has a bit more going on.
Yeah. But I could be.
Candy Crush is more like Bejeweled.
I've also never played.
in order to successfully pass them.
Before we get into the puzzle mechanics, though, or the gameplay, there is some light story, some lore behind why you're playing Puzznik.
Did you guys read the manual at all?
Yeah, I did.
I don't remember what the hell they said about it.
So please enlighten us.
Yeah. So there's a, the first page after the table of contents is the story.
So we have to take them at their word here and believe that this is part of the intended lore, even though it's more or less flavor copy and doesn't, you know, doesn't really say that this is the mechanics behind the game.
But the story that they give you is, you've shot your last terrorist.
What? You have, you have beaten the bad guys.
You've rescued the kingdom from the evil wizard and restored peace to the galaxy.
What's an arcade warrior supposed to do now?
Yeah, this isn't the lore.
This is, this is not lore, Mike.
No, but they're saying this is the story.
Like the reason that you, the player or the person you're controlling, making the moves inside the game is playing this game at all is because you have beaten every other video game you own.
So, all right, that your first sentence, you've shot your last terrorist was very shocking to me.
But now I actually, I kind of like the, I like that direction of like, yeah, yeah, we know you like to run around and jump and shoot the guns and save the princess and all that.
But like, try this out.
Yeah. And we all know you like exciting stuff.
Yeah, yeah. Like, why don't you try something else, okay?
I don't know. You've shot your last terrorist sounds like a threat from Al Qaeda.
You know, you just get like something in the mail.
You've shot your last terrorist, buddy.
We will be taking you down now.
You get that in the mail?
Well, yeah, it would be strange if you get any mail from it.
But I guess it happened at some point, right?
Before email? Before they could spam you?
Was Al Qaeda doing that?
Yeah, they were sending handwritten letters.
Dude, you never got one? That's so weird.
Lucky. All right.
So let's talk about Puzznik because there is a whole other game in here too, which is weird.
But like, let's just talk about Puzznik for a second.
There are 16 stages, 10 puzzles in each of these stages.
So it's kind of like a 1-1, 1-2 kind of deal.
So clearing one particular puzzle doesn't make you a genius.
You have to clear all 10 to kind of successfully clear the stage.
It makes 160 stages in total.
So there's certainly a lot of game here.
You clear every piece by matching like symbols and two or more combos.
But you have to do it before the timer hits zero.
And the timer is pretty aggressive in this game in the sense of like when more things happen on the screen.
Like I do agree that they ease you into it because you get, what is it, usually 90 seconds?
No, it depends on the size of the level, right?
Yeah, I've seen 70. I've seen 60.
Okay. So then, but it's still mostly forgiving early on.
But later on, when you have to actually think about what you're going to do, that clock is probably the most intimidating part of the game.
It's not just like, sure, given an infinite time scale, you could move these pieces around and figure out how to clear them so that you clear all of them.
Because again, that's the hook, right?
It's not just about matching symbols together all the time.
You have to make sure that you clear everything.
You can't leave a piece behind.
So if there are strategically three symbols of the same block, you can't clear two of them because now you'll be stuck with one.
And, you know, that's a fail state.
So you'll have to start over.
The matching, though, in general, the real thing behind it, right, is that there's placement of the remainder of the screen so that certain blocks can't be moved.
Or there are elevators that kind of move up and down the screen to transport blocks.
There are blocks that have to fall into other blocks.
It's the design of the specific level that makes it maybe a little bit hard to talk about this game in like a as a dialogue discourse.
But ultimately, that's the interesting hook of the game is the is the setup and then you having to solve it from that.
Right. They're always giving you they're kind of leading you with the way that it's set up.
Yeah, it's very much like an order of operations sort of puzzle.
I guess a lot of most puzzles are can be boiled down to that.
But it's very important here because you can very easily like soft lock a puzzle within like the first move.
And then you have to use a retry.
And that's not any fun.
But, yeah, it's a little.
But then there's also like some twitch reflex going on here, too, because of that, like movement and the fact that it's gravity based.
And sometimes you need to like move things while gravity is acting upon something else.
It's it's not as intense as that might sound, but it it can get a little tricky.
I'm curious what you guys think about my take on this.
But I think that this doesn't need the timer.
I get that it's like for that, like excitement or whatever.
I think that this is these are fine puzzles without the timer.
You're just going to keep retrying anyways when the time runs out.
So I don't know really what the timer adds personally.
I just want to look at the puzzle until I solve it with a game like this.
I know that that might not be the.
I agree. Like the intent of the of the developer.
But like to me, whenever there's a game like this and there's a timer and it feels unnecessary, I just I don't know.
They had something here where it was like, oh, this is different enough from Tetris because it's not about like, oh, my God, what's going to happen?
What where can I put this?
You're not panicking. It's more like let's sit and think about this puzzle.
And then they added the timer to kind of add that back in anyways.
Yeah, I agree.
Because like, again, you can fail without running out of time.
I guess isn't something right yet.
Like, oh, it's all about like just experimenting.
And and like, no, if you do something wrong, you're screwed.
So. Right. I think you're right.
Yeah, I would agree, too.
I don't think I can think of in their defense is that the, you know, 160 total puzzles.
The timer is designed to make these kind of quick bursts.
But that doesn't really matter if you wind up failing them anyway.
Like it's just going to take longer.
The game is incredibly forgiving, though, when it comes to retrying and starting over, because the only thing that happens is your score resets.
When you run out of retries, you don't like start back at the beginning of the stage you're on.
You just start right where you are and move forward.
I guess that that sort of balances it out, because if maybe the only reason you would care about the score is if you're trying to do it fast, like, you know.
Right. And the amount of time you have left is what, you know, boost your score the most.
So it's like all twitch reflex stuff.
Right. Because I've never solved a ribbix cube in my life.
But the people that do do that tend to have some pride with how fast they do it.
So, yeah, that's what I'm going to go with.
Now, this game doesn't have exactly that bejeweled candy crush thing that we were talking about, where, you know, there's like a cascade where you switch two blocks and they clear, but then more blocks fall down.
So they clear things that you didn't know, you know, like and all of a sudden it's like, wow, that caused a chain reaction of match threes and then a match four.
And then, you know, now there's these new symbols popping up.
It's not really this game, but you can design this game where, like, you match certain things to create other matches as well.
What's your play style here?
Are you, before you're even, like, before you're making moves, are you kind of counting the pairs and thinking about, like, where's the best piece to start?
Or are you just more of a, like, feel the movement, like, you know, solve the first pair in front of you and then deal with the next one and so on and so forth?
Just vibe it out?
Yeah, exactly.
When I started, it was more so just vibe it out, just move stuff around, it'll all start to click.
Then once I started to get those, like, straggler blocks, I was like, okay, I gotta actually, like, try something here.
So I did start counting, like, oh, do any of these have odd numbers?
Or are they sort of grouped in a way that you're going to have to do, like, a couple three-in-ones?
And, yeah, over time, once you start to learn the ways that the game is going to try and trick you, you become a bit more cognizant of it.
Yeah, I like to usually, like, try to just, you know, go with my gut on a first attempt.
And then on a second attempt, if I failed, I look at how I failed, and I also, like, really will pull back now and, like, look at, okay, if I put this here, like, where is everything going to line up?
Where am I going to accidentally put two things against each other that I don't want to disappear just yet?
And, like, I really start thinking a few steps ahead, but I do usually, because there's no real punishment for getting it wrong, I do usually try to go intuitively at first.
Which surprisingly works more often than you think, because I do feel like the game definitely gets more and more difficult, but I don't feel like it's a perfectly linear difficulty.
I feel like sometimes I'm like, okay, now we're getting difficult, and then I get, like, a real, like, lob ball in there.
Like, just that's super easy, and then another hard one, and then, like, one that's a little easier.
So sometimes I can just kind of solve it intuitively, and then when I fail those ones, that's when I'm like, all right, really sit back and, like, think out my moves before I actually make them.
But, like, when you do fail, like, do you have that moment of, like, goddammit, Joe, you're so stupid, like, how would you think that, Joe?
And then you just sort of beat yourself up for an hour or so?
Yeah, but I'm normally, like, thinking that way about myself at all times.
Oh, okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just making sure.
For the record. Just kidding, everybody.
No need to call any, like, support lines.
Can we get a check on Joe?
Yeah. And then, I think, Sean, I think you were alluding to this earlier, but this is something I'm calling temporary pairs, where, and this feels like the only part of the game that, I think, like, at a, sooner than later, it is necessary, but I feel like it's also wrong.
There's this ability to create a pair and then just drop the third one into place to cache all three at once, even though they didn't all, like, match at the same time.
Like, you're given, like, a few frames to kind of, like, get that third piece in there.
And that just doesn't feel right.
Like, I'm happy I solved the puzzle, but it doesn't feel like I correctly solved it.
Now, wait a minute, though.
Well, that's designed.
And I think, unless you're telling me otherwise, that it's only, like, yeah, the pieces didn't fall into place, but they were still as a result of your same last move.
It's not like you can make a move and then quickly make another move before something falls into place, right?
You kind of do have to do that.
Like, in some of these levels, the, like, there, you have to use, like, an elevator to move some, to move one piece into place that would then make contact with the second piece.
But in order to get the third piece in there, you then have to move that as well while the other one is on the elevator.
And so, like, there's some Twitch reflex stuff going on, and it's not entirely great with the way that the controls work because your cursor is super sticky.
And, like, it's like, I don't know.
It's odd.
I know the type of situation you're talking about, but I didn't take that as, like, oh, I kind of just cheesed the game because I snuck something in there before.
Oh, yeah, no.
That is the intent.
That's the design puzzle.
Yes, but I guess I was saying it doesn't feel like it because it's this weird thing where, like, if you did, you know, like, you only made a pair, and then the third one just kind of, you know, to the point of the elevator, like, just popped into place.
Not even at the same time.
Like, you don't have to necessarily wait until the third ones are exactly lined up as long as it's clearing the other two still.
If the third one ever touches, it adds it as part of the match.
But isn't that so fast that that's still sort of hard to do?
I think that that's what, like, what I'm saying is that even though it's like, yeah, I put it there, and now I'm seeing the other one come down and touch it.
It's like, yeah, that's all part of the same move.
Like, yeah, I guess it is weird because, like, it's like, yeah, I already had the thing on the elevator.
So it's not like, oh, like, I lucked out.
It's like, no, I put that there because that's where it's supposed to go.
Yeah. I feel like it's the game being, like, forgiving.
I'm like, yeah, you're not going to know the exact timing of the cycles.
So it's like, if you figured out the puzzle and you put it there, we'll let the cycle complete and see if you got it before we, before your stuff vanishes.
If anything, honestly, it's kind of impressive that they were able to program it that way to, like, know that, like, yeah, you got it right.
It just hasn't fallen into place yet.
Right, right. I mean, most of this game is, you know, more so than you making the groupings or, you know, strategically placing the blocks.
It's also avoiding the traps that they're setting up because while those elevators and such might be useful, they're also very easy to create, you know, like a permanent lock where you'll have to retry because you now, you know, you fell below the elevator or you locked a piece into one of those, like,
one tile shafts that now can't come out of it because, you know, gravity is always forcing itself downwards in this game so you can't lift that piece out.
You have to now retry the stage.
That's, like, that's the tough part of the game is avoiding all the traps that they've laid out, especially in the later levels.
Yeah, and that's why I was describing it as, like, it's mostly order of operations and only sometimes does, like, precise timing matter.
Uh, because if you get the order of operations wrong, you have now failed the level.
Thank you.
or making these very narrow passages,
that idea kind of remains the same,
and instead it's more just like,
can you match all of these different shapes?
Which again, that explains why they have to have the timer,
because otherwise it's just going to be a more tedious puzzle
instead of a more difficult puzzle.
I don't know. Yeah.
It's still tedious. Yeah.
I think I'm also just, I like this kind of puzzle.
I find them kind of fun,
but what I like about it is the satisfaction of sitting there
and figuring it out before I do it,
and being like, okay, wait, if I do this,
the difficulty to me lies in thinking enough steps ahead
and keeping it all straight in your head,
and then being right about that when you actually execute it.
The game kind of encourages you to not do that,
and to just kind of go with trial and error almost,
because it's like, well, time's ticking,
so you don't have time to just do it twice.
You don't have time to go over it in your head
and then do it on the thing.
So that's just like the one thing that kind of keeps,
I guess maybe they warned me about it,
about it being frustrating, but that frustrates me.
And then there's a completely other mode of this game,
which is not different enough to be like packaged as a sequel,
but it is very kind of them to include it in this game,
I feel like, because it is different enough
and branded different enough, right?
The first mode is called Puznik,
and the name of the game is Puznik.
This second mode, Gravnik, is Puznik,
but instead of directly controlling the blocks
to slide them along and match them,
you use, get a little of this,
gravity for Gravnik
to move all of the pieces at once.
So you have this giant directional pad
on the screen that you can see,
and it shows you which way you're pushing your directional pad,
and that moves every piece
in that upwards, left, right, or downwards direction.
Now, of course, that has a lot more implications
than the first game,
namely that there are some directions
that are just going to cause an immediate fail state,
depending on the way that the levels were designed.
So even though it's the same match rules,
touching identicals, vanishes the pieces,
I feel like some layouts just have, like,
one bad shift can strand an entire potential match
for forever and create an unwinnable stage
that you have to reset. So this one's even, like, a little more limiting
in, like, what's possible for your brain
versus what's the correct solution.
I think this one reminded me a lot of, like,
was it, like, 2048 or...
Yeah, that was...
I forget what the original...
I think the original one was called Threes,
but yes, 2048 is what I love.
Yeah, whichever one.
Because it has that, like,
you've got to make sure that you're not blocking yourself
because you're moving everything at the same time.
I don't know. I actually think that with what Joe was describing
of just sort of visualizing before acting,
like, this actually lends itself to that even more.
Um, uh, but maybe that's just me, but...
No, I completely agree.
I played this one much longer than the other one,
because I was really enjoying that.
I think this is an actually, like,
more interesting concept.
Maybe it doesn't have the same kind of,
uh, not ability,
but, like, the same potential
for super complex, um,
like, like, gameplay,
but I think it's a cooler puzzle design.
And you'll notice that, uh,
it's also Joe's favorite
because there is no timer anymore.
I was just going to bring that up,
and I do think that giving you a move limit
makes a lot more sense than a timer.
And granted, the move limit, I do think, um,
lends itself to this style puzzle
more than the other style,
but, like, yeah,
some of these, some of these
that are stumpers that take me a while,
I'm shocked that it only takes, like,
two moves to actually complete.
You know, like, that,
that's really cool to me
because I don't,
I have a hard time wrapping it around my head,
wrapping my head around how
this can be so difficult.
You know what I mean? Like, I'm just like, look,
and I'm like, yeah, I should just be able to look at this
and figure it out. But that's, that's the beauty
of the puzzle mechanic.
So, which mode clicks faster
for a new player?
Does, does Gravnik feel clever
or chaotic on first play
compared to Puznik?
I think it's more...
Yeah, I mean, I don't think they're,
either of them are super,
are super high concept.
I think that Gravnik is more intuitive
because you are just,
you're seeing your input
affect everything
in such a predictable way.
Whereas, with Puznik,
like, you're using a cursor
and, like,
the fact that gravity works
and, like, there's twos and threes,
like, there's a lot of, like,
wrenches that get thrown in,
whereas I think that
Gravnik is a lot more elegant.
But, I don't know.
Are there any mental tricks
or reading ahead strategies
for, like, figuring out
not just where everything's going
to move on first input,
but, like, after two shifts?
Is there a way to visualize that?
I don't have that capability.
Yeah. I can't think two steps
ahead of that. No, I, you know,
and that's, like, what I was thinking, too,
is, like, I cannot picture that,
like, no matter what I was doing.
But, in the earlier levels,
it was a little easier
to view, like,
okay, if I move everything
to the left, then the, you know,
there are certain pieces
on this board
that just act as blockers.
They don't have to be matched.
They're these gray tiles.
And they move
with everything else as well,
but they just kind of block
where things are going
to be placed. And so as they're moving along,
it's like, okay, I can kind of see that
that's shifting everything
to the left. So now my,
let's say I need to match
two red pieces and two green pieces.
It's like, okay, so now they're all, like,
next to each other. And so then when I move down,
they'll all touch.
Like, that felt easier
in the beginning, whereas in the later stages
where there's a lot of easy ways
to lock yourself out
if you just go in the wrong direction,
I wasn't sure how to, like,
get to that point.
And so even though, again,
very friendly system
of retries
and unlimited continues,
but I didn't feel
maybe as, like,
as a master planner here
as I was able to, like,
when I was looking at the whole board
in Puznick. I wonder what that says
about your brain.
I know, right?
I can't think ahead.
Don't hire me. You know, what's funny
is that, like, there is, like,
something about, though,
those blockers
and just the designs
of the puzzles about edge play
in this game using those ledges
or... Edge play?
Yeah, you know, You're gonna be frustrated.
Yeah, yeah, I did say that.
The box told this, too,
so we should be worried about that.
You know, just, like, riding the corners
and stuff like that
so that you hit everything
like, that's really the game
and then the matching part
can just kind of be,
like, coincidental at times.
Like, I was shifting these pieces around
just to try to get them
closer to each other but then it just
wound up matching?
I can see that
now that I think I understand
what you meant by that.
Other than that, though,
there's not much that separates
Puznick and Gravnik
because it isn't, like,
there was never a,
they, oh, if you match
these two symbols,
they act as bombs
that blow up surrounding symbols, too,
or, uh,
if you match these symbols,
they give you an additional move,
you know, from your max limit.
Like, neither game
kind of makes
anything special
of the symbols, they just make it
so that you have to match like symbols.
What's, like, an example of, uh,
a puzzle game that does do that?
Uh, don't know on the spot
but I feel like surely, uh,
that's not an uncommon
thing, right, to have, uh,
well, for instance, you know,
if we're gonna say Bejeweled, right,
if you match
four in a row
of something, then it doesn't become
just a, it doesn't go away,
it kind of creates this, uh,
crystal, the diamond,
you know, and now it's like,
oh, well, if you get the diamond
to match with anything,
then it, uh,
creates a larger,
uh, cascade.
It doesn't just match
the three in a row, it matches, like,
a box in a row
or whatever and if you match
five in a row, sometimes it creates,
like, uh, that's the one that
creates the diamond, not the crystal,
so on and so forth and then it's like,
you know, it basically creates
these additional
power-ups, if you will.
I'm not asking for power-ups
in this game but I think it would
have been interesting to explore that,
you know, uh, there are bomb symbols
and there are,
uh, extra retry symbols,
right, where, like, you're incentivized
to clear those
in order to help you,
like, maintain your score
or, um,
or just, you know,
blow up, uh,
pieces that you didn't,
that you couldn't figure out another way to solve.
I like, I like the idea
of those things and I wouldn't,
I wouldn't be opposed
to having them,
like, if someone were,
like, I'm going to add that to this game,
I'd be like, that sounds, that sounds great
but I don't think
it needs it. I do think it,
like, the simplicity,
at least Gravnik,
the simplicity of it,
like, I do think, I'm just surprised
at, like, how many levels
I can be playing
and how different each of them feel.
Um, but yeah,
I mean, like, I would never turn away,
like, having new little features
or new ways
that it works, but, uh,
but yeah, I think it's like,
and maybe, you know,
it's, maybe it's like,
that's why they package
two together because maybe it's a tough sell
because it's so simple,
but like, I think that maybe
there was a, if this were a mobile game
I just downloaded, I'm very satisfied with it.
And I don't think Gravnik
had the elevators.
It did not. So,
would that have been an interesting thing
to include? No,
I think that would mess with it too much.
You got, you got like a turn,
you got like a certain
amount of turns
and it's, it's like this
sort of turn-based thing
and then you've got some kind of
real-time element to it.
I think that's a little,
I don't know. Unless they redesigned
the elevator
so that it doesn't
go up in real time,
it moves one tile
every time you make a move
or something like that,
I could see it working.
Almost every version
of Puznik
that was released
and it goes on
for a while, Puznik was released
all the way up to the PlayStation.
So, starting with the arcade
in 89,
NES in 90,
there was, there was a Puznik,
pretty much almost exactly,
like there weren't like new features or anything,
but I guess there was
like a story mode,
maybe where you finally
took down your last terrorist.
Was it always for perverts?
In the PlayStation? You know,
that's interesting. I'm glad you brought that up,
Sean. No,
it wasn't always for perverts.
They pretty much got rid
of that part of the game
until the,
remember that weird console
that we talked about one other time,
FM Towns?
Ah, yes, the FM Towns.
That version did keep
the adult stuff
because I guess they figured
if you can afford
$800 or whatever it was
for an FM Towns back then,
you probably were an adult.
Okay. But there,
it's weird that like
the PlayStation version
didn't get like a,
I don't know, I'm not asking for 3D,
but like just not even
much change
from the NES version
of Puznik. It's kind of funny
to think that you would pay for that,
but almost every version
includes this box art
that is like,
kind of like what Palamedes was
for the dice, but it's for the blocks
where it makes them,
it makes them characters.
Oh yeah, they don't have really creepy
human legs though.
Yeah, yeah, exactly. No,
they do. Well,
not, yeah, they're cartoon legs,
not like, cartoon legs,
not anatomically
correct human legs.
And I don't want to
critique the box art
too much because I'm not sure how many
people look at the,
the chapter art
or whatever for our episodes,
but like, if you're looking at it
with us, it's weird that some
of the blocks have faces
and then there are also
blocks on the screen
that don't have faces
and are just those
same blocks,
you know, it's like, what,
what's going on there?
Why, did they not become
real people yet?
That's what I was going to say,
like, you know how there are some people
that you know
have like,
cogent thought
within their,
their brain, but then there's also
those people that don't actually
exist. Yeah.
And then if you look
at the NES box art
by comparison,
uh, it's like,
it's like some 1960s
jazz album cover.
Like, it's very like
postmodern,
uh, minimalism,
like geometric shapes.
I think Puznick needs to be,
like, they're, they're really
tooting their own horn
here. Like, this is like,
is, if it was something
so ubiquitous
as a Tetris,
you can get away with this,
but, I mean,
and maybe I'm
underselling, or I just don't
really know how big Puznick
was back in the day,
but I think it's
kind of tooting its own horn
here a bit. And then forgive me
for this, but I have to ask it.
I genuinely do not
know the answer, so have fun with me
here. Is Puznick supposed
to be like a picnic
for your brain?
Like, is that, is that what Puznick,
what's the Nick part?
Uh, yeah, I don't know.
Uh, yeah, I don't,
I don't think it's, sorry,
picnic for your brain,
but, uh, well,
I mean, I added that flavor
because it's,
you know, it,
no, I understand that.
yeah, I'm adding,
I'm adding the tagline,
you know, their tagline is,
this will frustrate you
to no relief.
Like at a picnic. Yeah.
I'd say like, he's like a beat Nick,
but, Oh,
I like that. Yeah.
I like that could be what the Nick is for.
And then for grav Nick,
it's like a beat Nick,
but for gravity.
I should have known.
It's gravity for your brain.
And, uh,
nostalgia is nostalgia for your brain.
Um, and somehow that's going to tie into the essential games list.
I had a pretty good time with Puzz Nick.
I'm not, uh, ashamed by that.
It's pretty, it's pretty straightforward,
but it also can get very,
uh, complex. And I enjoyed,
like, I wouldn't say like I was stumped on a puzzle necessarily.
I just kind of like ran out of time.
Uh, it wasn't like, Oh,
I'll never beat seven dash three.
Like they got me.
Uh, but at the same time,
I probably stopped because of the,
like just the time limit that I have in life.
Uh, and not necessarily because I stopped enjoying the game.
I think it's a pretty good game.
I don't think it's like enough of a game to,
and especially because it's put it on so many things to be like,
Oh yeah, this is like an essential NES game.
Like when I think of the,
the library of the NES,
this is right up there with the greats.
I don't think it's that,
but I think it's a pretty solid,
uh, puzzle game by all means.
And, uh, probably holds up in the,
in the realm of puzzle games better than,
you know, shoot me for saying this Dr.
Mario. Like, I don't know.
I don't, I don't really like that game,
but Puzznik, I'm enjoying it.
Joe, uh,
this game has unlocked memories of,
of types of games that I liked when I was a kid.
There's two in particular that this is,
that kind of reminded me of one is a Game Boy game called Boxel,
where you're playing this,
you're, you're pushing boxes.
You can only push them forward.
You can't pull them back. So you're like,
you can get stuck in a lot of ways.
And it's a, it's a puzzle game kind of similar to this.
Um, a little aside,
I have a crazy Mandela effect.
I swear the game was called Box It,
but there's no record of that online.
It's always been Boxel.
Um, second,
uh, it reminds me of the,
uh, ice path puzzles in Pokemon Gold,
Silver and Crystal,
where you, Gravnik reminds me of that,
where you, you, you move in one direction,
you slide all the way across in that direction until you hit a barrier.
So you have to kind of use the barriers to decide like how to get yourself into the direction you want to go,
which is kind of what Gravnik is doing.
And I love both of those things.
And I've, I've really enjoyed those.
I remember like long car rides playing Boxel forever and everything.
I just don't know if,
uh, I think that like now as an adult,
this is just, I don't know.
I just, to me, as I've grown up,
like, I don't want to sit down and just play this all the time anymore.
You know, I, I think it needs for me personally,
I need a little, I need a little more stimulation because I'm just overstimulated at all times.
And this game is too frustrating with the edge play and everything.
So, sorry,
I just didn't know where I was going with that.
So I'll just like go onto the edge play.
But, um, yeah,
I think that, uh,
I really liked this game.
I recommend it if you like puzzle games,
but I mean, you know, it's not,
it's not anything to write home about is what I'm trying to say.
So I don't think I would call it essential.
Sean. Yeah.
I'll echo that. I,
neither of these games have enough to it to really,
uh, at least in my opinion,
be a full like release of something.
Uh, I'm glad that they added Gravnik.
I think I prefer Gravnik.
And if it was,
if it was just Puznik,
there'd be even more of like,
uh, what do you take me for?
Uh, you know,
like I, I wonder how much this game MSRP for,
I guess, but I,
we've said that about a lot of these puzzle games or just a lot of these
like simpler games.
So it's, that's not anything new.
I did, I did like them as they stood.
There just really isn't that much going on here,
uh, in terms of content.
So not essential.
One last thing about the arcade version of the game.
Keep going. Yeah.
Uh, I don't know how to say this,
but the,
uh, so it,
it gives you the name of the person that's going to be revealed first.
And you,
you clear that part of the stage and then you see just the face and then you
see, um,
the private areas.
And then you see,
and then you see the full picture.
It's a little strange,
right? The order there.
Oh, wow. Like,
shouldn't the, you would think that like you would be teased with everything and then get
the, the delicate area.
It's like anti censorship.
So I thought you were saying we should go like name last.
Yeah. Well, I mean,
you know, we should at least get the name again.
It's kind of weird that the name comes off,
right? Like the name is revealed.
Then it's not revealed any longer.
And then it's like, okay, now just here's a naked person.
It's like, well, I'd like to know.
Gotcha. So really we should have talked about this during the bubble bath babes episode on the nostalgia
bites. Why?
Why would we talk about that?
Oh yeah. Yeah. Thank you.